This is what is meant by sanity. If a
person is lucid enough to be able to
hold such an intention, this would
consider them to be sane.
And
the fourth
criteria is that the person be a
resident. A resident meaning
not traveling.
not in travel
and the fifth that the person be healthy
meaning the opposite of sick or ill.
Now what is meant by illness?
Illness that
allows a person to break his fast in
Ramadan.
illness
has
three
types
that would allow a person to break his
fast during Ramadan.
You have an illness which is directly
affected by fasting.
Meaning if a person fasts,
this makes the illness worse. Or if a
person fasts,
this prohibits
a person's
from healing from this illness. This
delays a person person's recovery.
Or number three, fasting doesn't affect
their illness at all.
However,
it affects
some kind of medication that they have
to take that would normally break their
fast.
These are the three types of illness
which are intended when discussing
illness that acts as an allowance to
break a person's fast during the day of
Ramadan.
Three,
number one, the illness is increased by
fasting fasting.
Number two,
the illness is prolonged
by fasting.
Number three,
a person
is not necessarily affected, the illness
is not affected by the fasting.
However, fasting impedes
their
impedes their therapy for the
illness.
they have to take for instance some kind
of medication
that
is taken orally and this will break a
person's fast. So the illness itself is
not affected by fasting but it demands
taking some kind of medicine or
medication
orally that will break a person's fast.
And so this is what's intended by
illness. When the scholars, the Islamic
jurists, the fukah discuss illness as
being a valid excuse
to break a person's fast during the
month of Ramadan.
Traveling.
What is a traveler? What is meant by
traveling?
Traveling
is not something that can be quantified
by distance.
It's not something that can particularly
be quantified
by any particular state of being.
Meaning a person is uncomfortable or a
person is comfortable.
This would mean that they're traveling
or not. person may be a traveler and
perfectly comfortable.
Likewise, a person may be a resident and
be very uncomfortable.
Also, it's not dictated by distance.
There's no particular distance that will
discern the traveler from the resident,
distinguish the traveler from the
resident.
Traveling
is whatever is considered
to be travel
amongst any people of a place.
If a person were to go to this place,
everyone would naturally
according to their customs
view this as being traveling.
A person prepares himself. He has to
plan. has to plan a route. , and they
have to leave the
borders of their city in which they
reside
and people consider this to be travel.
This person is considered a traveler.
Now, the scholars of Islam all agree
due to
the verses of the Quran
that travel and illness are a valid
excuse for breaking a person's
fast.
And that every traveler
and every person who is ill according to
the
criteria that we mention is
permissible for them to break their
fast.
The only thing that the scholars differ
on is what is better.
Is it better for the person to fast if
he's able even though he's traveling? Is
it better for a person to fast if he's
ill,
if he's able to? This is what the
scholars differ on, but they all agree
that travel, an illness, are the chief
excuses for valid excuses for a
person breaking his or her fast.
And in light of that,
we have
very common questions that are
usually asked during Ramadan,
during fasting, people are unclear
about.
And many of these will be cleared up
if we mention the pillars of fasting
what is fasting?
When a person does this, what makes them
fasting?
What makes them not fasting?
Well, fasting is very easy. It has two
pillars. Two.
If you have both of these pillars
present at the same time
from the break of dawn
until the sun sets. Congratulations. You
are fasting. This is what fasting is two
pillars.
Number one, an
intention.
And number two,
refraining from anything that will
otherwise break your fast intentionally.
That's it. Because fasting
isn't something that you do per se. It's
something that you refrain from, isn't
it? It's not doing that which would
break your fast. That's what fasting is.
That's what a psalm is.
And so intention
is that a person have the intention to
fast before the break of dawn of the day
that they have intended to fast.
They have to have had that intention.
Tomorrow I am going to fast and this has
to have been made before the break of
dawn. Does the person have to say
anything? No. Intentions are in the
heart. As a matter of fact, it's
impossible to do something without an
intention. A lot of times people worry
about their intention. Is my intention
correct? Is it valid? Right? I have to
say my intention verbally. There's no
time in which the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam or his companions
ever verbalized
their intentions for fasting or praying
or any other act of worship.
And so merely having the intent to fast
the next day, you have the intention.
There's nothing you have to say.
And then it is refraining from that
which will break a person's fast.
Now question is what will break a
person's fast?
There are
only five things that will break a
person's fast.
This kinds of talks are not intended
to make everyone present a scholar in
the affair of fasting for instance
that takes years obviously and studying
and so forth.
This is to give a person general
guidelines
to go with.
And then if something out of the
ordinary happens to a person, what do
they do?
Ask.
You ask.
If something out of the ordinary occurs,
then you ask specifically.
You don't ask
Google.
You don't ask chat GPT.
You ask the people of knowledge.
You call,
you
go, you
write a message and tie it to a pigeon's
foot. whatever it is, but you go and you
interact with a person of knowledge. You
ask
this is what happened. What do I do?
Anything outside of these five
will not break your fast.
You ready? It's very easy.
One and two.
eating or drinking anything
intentionally.
Eating or drinking anything
Number three,
making yourself vomit.
Self-induced vomiting.
Meaning that if you don't make yourself
vomit, if it was unintentional, your
fast is correct. You haven't broken your
fast. It is to make yourself vomit.
You ate something suspicious for and now
it's crawling back up your throat.
You're going to be sick. So,
you make yourself vomit. This is one of
the types of prophetic medicine is
inducing vomiting to clear out the
stomach.
Number four and five are specific to
females which is
menration or postpartum
bleeding. These two will break a
person's fast.
And
the one that is general to men and
women, the sixth point is
sexual
intercourse
or that which brings about a similar
result. This is what breaks a person's
fast.
Anything outside of this will not break
a person's fast.
Those six things,
five
if we count
to be one, the same thing.
[Arabic recitation]
are you running for me?
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Allah.
Ramadan.
[Silence]
You read
took for
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
in
the verses that he dedicated of the
Quran to
one of the five pillars of this religion
of Islam.
He tells us subhanahua
about the pillar of fasting.
He says that which translates to, "Oh
you who have believed,
fasting has been prescribed upon you all
as it has upon those who have preceded
you in order that you may obtain tawa.
In order that you may truly become from
amongst the righteous.
in order that you may truly obtain
safety from the torment of the hellfire.
He says,
"An appointed number of days,
a quantified number of days.
Out of all of this year in which we have
to eat and drink of that which Allah has
blessed us,
one month
is set aside for fasting."
He has identified that month
when he says the month of Ramadan
in which the Quran was revealed.
Notice how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
makes the most prominent feature of
Ramadan
not fasting,
not eating,
not even salah.
But the center thrust and most prominent
feature of Ramadan is that it was the
month in which the Quran was revealed as
a guidance to all of mankind
and a criterion
from the revelation of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala.
The Quran is a criterion.
Allah
refers to the Quran as
that the Quran is. It is a criterion.
Meaning that the person who learns the
Quran
with a pure heart
will learn the distinction
between truth and falsehood.
The distinction between right and wrong.
The distinction between good and bad,
pure and impure, good and evil,
lawful and unlawful.
Without this criterion,
no matter how smart a person is,
no matter how wellstudied or traveled,
no matter a person's experience or age,
no matter their level of wisdom, they
will never truly obtain criterion in its
fullest form without the book of Allah,
the Quran.
Allah says, "Hence, whoever of you
witnesses
the duration of that month, then he is
to fast it.
Yet if you are sick or traveling, then
you are to make those days up from other
days remaining throughout the year."
He then tells us subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that it is not difficulty that he
desires for us
rather it is ease
and that we may fulfill these days these
numbered days of fasting
and that we may thank Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
truly
and truly reveal fear Allah.
Then notice something very interesting.
The following verse
Allah says, "And if my slaves ask you
about me,
then I am near.
I answer
and respond
to the prayers of those who call out to
me.
So let them
then respond to me and believe in me
truly in order that they may obtain
guidance.
These are three things
here. We have fasting,
we have the Quran and we have dua.
These three things are mentioned in that
order
in these verses regarding the month of
Ramadan.
Fasting in the day,
it's something that is general, but many
people are exempted from fasting.
Fasting is not something that everyone
is able to do.
is not something that everyone is
required to do.
It is required upon people who meet a
certain set of criteria.
Those who are pregnant are breastfeeding
or traveling or ill or very old to where
fasting is very difficult.
These individuals are exempted from
fasting. But this doesn't mean that they
are exempted from the fruits of Ramadan
because that is not the most prominent
feature of Ramadan.
The most prominent feature of Ramadan is
that it was the month in which the Quran
was revealed.
And so Allah chose of all the months for
us to fast in the month in which the
Quran was revealed.
Why is that?
If we notice that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us that he has designated
the months of the year as 12.
Of these 12, a third, four of them are
sacred.
However, Ramadan
is not one of these four sacred months.
Ramadan is outside of this third.
It is an additional month that has been
made sacred by Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala
that prepares us for those three
consecutive sacred months.
And so
what is the connection between fasting
and damag?
The connection is that it's almost as if
fasting in itself is really just a
preparation
in the daytime for us to recite the
Quran at night
so that we can better understand the
Quran.
so that we can bring ourselves down,
anchor ourselves.
Fasting has a habit of really
setting our priorities straight
that I can leave off not just what I
want or what I but I can actually
refrain from the stuff of life itself.
I can actually refrain from that which I
need to stay alive for a certain number
of hours during the day.
Then I can leave off these other things.
I don't really need them
in order that when the nighttime comes,
a person is listening or reciting the
book of Allah with
his priorities set straight.
with a little more clarity
under a different light
from a different angle.
And that is really
the center thrust of Ramadan. That is
how it is designed. The worship of
Ramadan is designed around the book of
Allah, the Quran.
That a person will fast in day. This
will help to expedate his sins, purify
his heart,
reset his priorities, so that at night
he may better hear the words of Allah.
That these words may come upon a heart
that has been eagerly preparing itself
throughout the day.
This is the purpose of fasting in
Ramadan.
And for this reason, the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam tells us
that whoever stands in prayer each night
throughout the month of Ramadan, what is
passed of his sins will be forgiven
with intention and hopefulness.
with im and
so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has designated this month a month that
we reacquaint ourselves with the Quran
and I'm not just speaking about
reading it as many times as we And
I'm not speaking about
just letting the words wash over us
without an attentive heart.
reading the Quran, listening to the
Quran
with an open heart and an attentive mind
and ear
as if you are hearing these verses
almost for the first time.
That each and every verse is meaningful.
that each and every verse is understood
at least in an apparent way.
This is what is meant by reading the
Quran. This is the purpose of the Quran.
As for us, just going through the
motions without our heart present
or without understanding what the verses
of the Quran mean. This is not something
that is going to change us in any
meaningful way.
Yes, a person who recites a letter from
the Quran for them is one and for each
is 10 times.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam he
told us this.
[Silence]
many of us we we know these narrations
that our prophet tells us that each
letter we are rewarded for its
recitation. But why? This is an
incentive for us to read the Quran.
Not just so that we can
earn these hassat,
but so that the meanings of the Quran
truly connect and resonate with us.
And a person who
fails to reflect on the Quran,
a person who fails to seek understanding
of the meaning of the Quran. This person
has abandoned
a large portion of the Quran. He's
abandoned its meanings.
These meanings are what we are
desperately in need of.
Often times
we look at the Quran
and we have reduced it in our lives to a
a ceremonious
book.
A book that is used for ceremony.
We recite it in salah.
We recite it during Ramadan,
but that's
all it is for.
When it comes to questions that we have
when we are seeking answers,
do we seek them from the Quran? truly
I know of course as a Muslim every one
of us we say
yes the Quran is my guide but is it
really
if you were to look at your actions look
at your life look at your choices do
they really reflect your understanding
and belief of the Quran or do they
reflect the understanding or other
beliefs
This is why the Quran was sent, why it
has been preserved.
So that the Quran may be a guiding
light, a criterion.
It's so that we can be guided by its
meanings.
And there are so many misconceptions
with respect to the Quran.
Many people are overwhelmed with
feelings about the Quran and
misconceptions that sometimes we don't
even stop to really quantify.
Many of us are under the impression that
the Quran is somehow not clear or that
it is incomplete without other things or
that it is only to serve a very niche
purpose in our lives and this couldn't
be further from the truth.
The Quran is clear.
Allah describes the Quran as mubin.
It is not only clear in itself but
clarifying to others.
And the Quran has to be reintroduced
into our lives. It has to be that is
what we are missing.
We are missing the influence of the
Quran in our lives truly.
Not just lip service,
not just I read it this many times or
I've read it before or assuming we
already know what it says.
We are all individually and as a whole
in dire need
of returning
and reestablishing
the Quran in our lives,
in our personal lives, in our private
lives and in our public existence.
was asked
what is
what was the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's character like
and she said
she responded that his character
was the Quran.
If you want to read the most detailed
description
of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
biography, of his life, of his
character, of the inner workings of his
mind and heart they are in the pages and
in the verses of the Quran.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Stand shoulder tosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps.
[Silence]
nameus.
Alhamdulillah.
Foreign
[Silence]
Amen.
All
Allah.
[Silence]
Allahel.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
All
for
Allah.
Allah
Allahbel
[Silence]
Allahel
act.
[Silence]
All
Brothers and sisters, asalam alalaykum.
I have some very important announcements
to make.